hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine lieben
freunde zu einem neuen video auf meinem
kanal und zwar stelle ich euch heute die
22 verrücktesten weltrekorde vor das
hier ist der erste komische weltrekord
den ich euch heute zeigen möchte und
zwar ist es eine person die 331.000
bienen auf seinem körper sitzen hat ja
ganz normaler sommertag hier in köln das
hier ist der nächste werde weltrekord
den ich euch heute zeigen möchte und
zwar ist das ein 25.000 dollar teures dr
dafür kriegt so ein geiles auto diese
personen hier hält den rekord für die
längste zeit mit dem ganzen körper im
schnee stehen und zwar 46 minuten ich
heute schon rum wenn ich im winter ohne
winterjacke vor die tür gehen muss der
typ ii hält den weltrekord für die
meisten löffel die einfach so an ihm
dran festhalten und zwar 50 stück also
immer besteck dabei
und das hier ist eine 81,8 meter langen
zigarre
wenn man die raucht alter direkt schau
das ist ein foto vor dem weltrekord wo
leute den meisten gebratenen reis
gemacht haben und zwar ist das reis für
insgesamt 7000 leute ich würde das in
einem abendessen das hier sind 4500
leute die gleichzeitig einen hula hoop
ring um sich rum schwingen und zwar für
sieben minuten
ich schaffe das nicht mehr allein für
sieben minuten dieser typ p hält den
weltrekord dafür dass er am längsten ein
basketball auf seiner zahnbürste die
einem hund hat drehen kann
ich kriege haben es nicht mehr geschafft
diesen satz habe ich richtig
auszusprechen dieser typ hier jongliert
gerade zwei kettensägen und hat das 62
mal geschafft hält damit dementsprechend
den weltrekord und wenn
erst danach nicht mehr geschafft hat hat
jetzt wahrscheinlich keine hände mehr
102 leute nackt in einer achterbahn
was denken sich denn die leute so dann
wenn sie morgens aufstehen wollte ruhig
mein 101 freundin nackt achterbahn und
setzten damit einen neuen weltrekord auf
wie die etwa 1200 leute die gleichzeitig
eine gesichtsmaske auftragen decker habt
ihr langeweile und das hier ist einfach
die größte und schwerste christbaumkugel
die es gibt und zwar die 20 kilo und hat
einen durchmesser von 70 cm dicker das
war größer als mein tannebaum den ich
dieses jahr hatte das hier ist ein zwei
tonnen schwerer gummibänder bei dicker
ich frage mich echt gar nichts mehr das
hier sind 300.000 bierdeckel und die
haben das mal als fun fact hier die
haben das einen extra umgestoßen und
irgendwie stehen lassen weil sie zeigen
wollten hey das ist nicht irgendwie mit
kleber geklebt oder so sondern die
fallen alle um das heißt schlussendlich
hat er es für nicht zusammengebaut jetzt
seht ihr den kleinsten mann der welt mit
einer größe von 54 zentimetern und den
größten mann der welt mit einer größe
von zwei metern 51 die sich die hand
geben
das ist so ihre alter der typ hat
einfach 2500 sneaker und ich denke dass
ich mit meinen 20 schulen schon zu krass
bin das hier ist eine 7 kilogramm
schwere zwiebel ja ich glaube auch dass
man da nichts mehr zu sagen muss ihr
seht ihr ein 800 meter langes drachen
kostüm beziehungsweise keinen drachen
kostümen sondern irgendwie so ein ding
was die darum tragen zum volksfest da
aber 800 meter jäger das fasten
kilometer haben
das hier ist der größte wirklich
funktionierende koffer auf der welt und
zwar sehr einfach zwei meter groß
ja ich sage da braucht da die beiden
leute die haben sich einfach zwölf
stunden lang die hand geschüttelt
ja wenn man sonst nichts besseres zu tun
hat und dass hier sind 10.000 leute die
gleichzeitig eine straße fegen begann
10.000 leute gleichzeitig meine wohnung
putzen würden ja werde wahrscheinlich
immer noch nicht sauber kommen
allerdings auch zum letzten komischen
weltrekorde ich euch heute vorstellen
möchte und weiß eigentlich gar nicht so
komisch aber ich find's einfach
unfassbar krass wie laut das einfach ist
dieser golden retriever hält nämlich den
weltrekord für das lauteste bällen mit
113 dezibel 113 dezibel nur kurz zur
erklärung ist sicher so laut wie ein
presslufthammer oder eine kettensäge
oder eine china böller
also ich möchte nicht gern diesen hund
bellen hören an der stelle wird das
heutige wieder seitlich auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn auch ich meine
vorstellungen von einigen der komischen
weltrekorde aller zeiten gefallen hat
der last und einen daumen hoch unter dem
video aus schreibt ihnen in die
kommentare
welchen weltrekord ihr am komischsten
fandet abonniert zudem gern meinen kanal
falls sie keine weiteren videos mehr
verpassen möchte das ist kostenlos und
der anteil der lupe
[Musik]